Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
Guys, I know it's 11.44, but that means we have 15 minutes left before we can finish farming Valorant.
Guys, you don't understand!
We can still farm Valorant for free money, guys!
I have to go live before it's too late!
Guys, thank you for the Twitch Prime view!
Thank you, thank you!
Yes, if you guys didn't know, there's a special promotion where everybody's basically farming Valorant for...
Valorant!
Thank you for the gifted subs!
Doug, thank you for the 10 gifted subs!
Thank you, thank you!
No, I don't usually stream this late.
Guys, I was waiting.
Guys, I told you, I'm Plan Z, okay?
Guys, this is what I do.
I wait until anybody is free to play with me.
And usually, it's really late at night.
Please.
If I could, I'd play earlier.
This is literally the only time people play with me.
I told you guys, we all know this.
Bro, she's cooked.
Thank you for the 5 gifted subs!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you for letting me farm Valorant one last time before it's all gone.
Thank you for the 5 gifted subs!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you for the 10 gifted subs!
I just need non-degenerate friends.
That's fucked, guys.
Anyway, so we're going to be playing with... we actually ended up getting Mace in the end.
He woke up from his... he had a very long day.
I would know because I saw him on Gale's stream.
And apparently he had double blocks of scrims.
And I saw him on Gale's stream again.
And then he took a nap.
And now he's here.
So...
I was surprised he still wanted to play today.
Because I was...
I was just like, bro, it's okay.
Just fucking sleep.
You don't have to.
And then he just showed up.
And I was like, oh shit, okay.
And we're also grabbing Mac as our DPS third.
I literally told him, I was like, he's climbing.
Who would have thought?
He stopped his fucking Black Panther arc.
Mac stopped his goddamn Black Panther arc.
And now his Eternity peaked 160.
Who was right, guys?
Who the fuck was right?
He was like, no, my Black Panther is not a throw.
Oh yeah, now he stopped fucking playing Black Panther and he's finally climbing.
Mac was right.
Let him play.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Bro, I was like, I was like, are you serious?
Your Eternity...
He had like a...
He had a fucking 8 game win streak yesterday while fucking drunk.
But he only played Starlord.
He didn't play anything else.
And I'm just like, what was I?
Was I a fucking guinea pig for your sick experiments during that time?
So yes, he's now, he's now higher ranked than me.
He should not try out Storm.
Like, I swear to God.
Alright, so like I said, this is not like we're streaming until we get top 500.
It's literally we either lose Eternity or we get top 500.
There's no in between.
I'm not going to do a marathon.
I'm not going to do a long, a super fucking long stream today.
Because it's already super late for a lot of you guys.
And like, I'm so sorry.
I know like a lot of you guys, I didn't give you guys like a time of like when I was going to go live today.
Because even I didn't know when I was going to go live today.
So like, I'm so sorry.
For everybody that like waited in chat.
So like, I was going to stream regardless today.
Of like who I get.
Like, um.
So I really appreciate everybody waiting out.
To be like, I must.
I mean for enabling my addiction as well.
Like, I really appreciate it guys.
Like, for all of you guys for enabling this addiction.
Yeah, thank you for the 100 basic.
Thank you, thank you.
I've been kidnapped and I'm in Doki's basement.
Please help.
That is a fucking lie.
Because I was even like, no, you should sleep.
Because sleep is so much more important.
And it literally, the next message was like, I'm awake.
Let's fucking get it.
Like.
I gave him an out.
I literally gave him the key.
I gave him the key to go out.
And he locked himself in the basement.
Like, that's his own fault.
Like, he had the free.
I gave him free will and he refused to take it.
To the end.
So right now we're just waiting for Max King to end.
And then we should be good to go.
We should be good to go.
I have no, I honestly have no idea.
Like, if the games are gonna be bad or good.
I don't know.
Because it's gonna be like an eternity three stack.
So like, I've never had that privilege before.
So like, I've never, I've never had the privilege to be in an eternity three stack.
So I could go, oh hey look, Dosiris in his own three stack.
Oh man, I hope, I hope we're not gonna play it.
Because I know he's playing with Beast Halo.
And I know Beast Halo is a fucking insane tank player.
So I hope he doesn't fire me.
I'm just a little, I'm just a little guy.
What the fuck?
Okay.
I'm just, I'm just a little guy.
BXB, thank you for the five gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
Sloppy, thank you for the five gifted subs.
Thank you for letting me farm.
Thank you for letting me farm Valorant for, I believe, ten more minutes until it's all over.
Oh shit, he's here.
Alright, let's go.
Alright, I'm a little scared though.
Who's being, who's the discord kitten?
Who could it be?
Alright, I'm just a little worried.
Just a little bit.
I have, I have no, I don't even know how long Q's are going to be too.
Are Q's bad in this ELO?
I hope they're not that bad.
I heard like some high, wait, how high rank is Meece's ulti count?
Okay, good, he lost it all.
That's fine.
That's, that means games might...
Okay, dick.
That means Q's will be faster.
It means Q's will be faster.
Guys, that's what I mean.
I don't want to wait, I don't want to wait like 20 minutes for a game.
I just, I just want to play.
Ducky, please.
I don't, I don't know what the average wait time is.
Oh, it's a minute.
Okay, that's nice.
It's only a minute and 20 seconds.
I saw like for some people.
For people who are too high ranked and they're too high ranked.
That their estimate time was just unknown.
Like, like you don't even know.
You just gotta sit there.
So, I don't, I don't want to, I don't want to deal with that.
Like, I don't know, I don't want to deal with unknown.
Nexy, thank you for the 10 gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
A star guy, thank you for the $10 donation.
Be honest, when was the last time you slept?
I actually woke up from a nap.
Like a three hour, two hour, two to three hours nap.
And I just slept a lot after the New Year's countdown.
I just like, after New Year's countdown, I did some, I did a little bit of work stuff.
And then I went to, I actually, for the first day one of, oh my god, this is a full eternity.
Oh my god, fucking, oh my god.
I knew I was gonna, I knew it.
I knew I was gonna play against that stack.
I fucking knew it.
Oh my god, I, bro, I fucking knew I was gonna play against this dude and use Halo.
I don't know who their third is.
I just know they're three stacking as well.
It is that stack.
I should have dodged.
I'm not even party leader.
Alright, guys.
Ban Bruce, oh yeah, we should ban Bruce better.
I don't want to play against the Hulk player.
Hella second, that's true.
That's true, he is a hella one trick.
Well, he's not a hella one trick.
His Hawkeye is actually insane too.
I remember, that's why I like, literally, I remember after the game where he was Hawkeye, he like, he added me.
And I was like, damn, your fucking Hawkeye is insane.
Of course, oh my god.
Of course, they banned Starlord.
I literally told Mace, I was like, yeah, Max is an insane Starlord player.
And then Mace was like, what do we do if he's banned?
And I was like, I don't fucking know, man.
I was like, I don't know, I hope it doesn't happen, I guess.
I was like, I don't know, his other characters, it's like 50-50.
His Starlord's fucking carry, like, his Starlord's fucking insane.
Alright.
Alright, we'll see how this goes.
If not, we just, I guess we dodge?
We dodge next time.
I can't believe it, of course.
Of course the first game, the first game this happens.
It's alright, I believe in his magic.
I believe.
Alright, just keep Mace alive.
Keep Mace alive, that's been the plan, that will always be the plan.
I believe.
Why ban Iron Fist?
Maybe this guy plays Iron Fist, I'm pretty sure.
Yeah?
Oh my god.
I don't know if my voice chat is broken.
Wait,
his orb is gone because of it.
I don't know if my VC is broken, because it's always there.
Oh, his Hawkeye is insane though.
Oh my god.
Okay, I have to...
There's a Hawkeye to the left.
Oh my god, I don't know.
I don't know if my VC is working!
Oh, I should have warmed up.
This being the first game is not it for me.
I...
Oh my god.
This being the first game, oh my god.
No, this is insane on Hawkeye.
I have ult here.
Mantis ult first?
Is it possible?
There's a Hawkeye there, Hawkeye's half.
Hawkeye's one, Hawkeye's one.
There's a Magneto on her, Wolverine.
Alright, nice.
Alright, it's working!
The VC is working!
Go!
Oh, I need heals, I need heals Mantis.
I need...
Oh my god, guys.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared of this Hawkeye.
This Hawkeye's actually insane.
Oh yeah, he's actually his teammate too.
Run!
Oh, I can ult this here.
Malting.
Don't peek it though, you're not gonna survive.
Oh my god!
There's so many things on my screen!
We can just die on point.
Alright.
Oh my god, these games are so much harder.
I miss my GM lobbies.
I miss my GM lobbies!
Oh my god, I hate these lobbies!
I can't fucking peek anything!
Everybody get in!
Oh my god!
I'm fucking a baby!
A fucking baby!
The price I pay.
I can't see you, Wolverine.
Oh, it doesn't matter, I die.
I die!
We're down, we're down too.
Alright.
I miss it.
Yes, I realize how good we had it.
Being a little...
A little baby.
Oh my god.
There's his web pick!
Nice.
That's huge!
That's a huge ult!
I'm ulting, I'm ulting.
Nice.
I'm damage boosting it.
Luna,
Luna!
Oh my god!
That's fun!
We're so healthy!
Oh my god!
Oh, I'm in the...
Big boy lobbies.
This is so...
I'm so stressed out.
I'm ready.
I'm so stressed out already.
Guys, I didn't even warm up.
I just went straight into it.
I was like, alright, I'll wait for my nap.
Just walked my dog.
And I guess it's time to stream and play Marble Rivals!
That's my first game!
Turkey is a big boy now.
I wanna be back at my baby table.
I don't...
Oh my god, I'm so stressed out.
I remember our good times.
When I was a baby in the group.
This is fun.
Alright.
The good times.
The good times back then.
Oh my god, I can't even like...
I can't even like, hesitate at all.
Like, it's just...
Frozen?
I'm on Venom.
Venom low, Venom low!
Venom one!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I need heals, Mantis, why don't you?
Oh no!
Mantis!
I just needed a little bit of heals!
You're down a healer.
I just...
Oh, didn't she just watch?
She just watched it all happen!
Oh!
Just a fucking baby!
Oh my god.
It's okay, we just...
Wait, there's somebody on my Magneto.
I think...
I think BC is broken.
No, BC...
Okay.
Here we go.
That's fine.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure BC is broken.
I'm so fucking sure.
Woo!
I wish the BC was...
better.
Alright.
That's fine.
We're all alive.
Let's dance!
Oh, don't roll, don't roll.
Oh, that's fine.
I'm hiding behind that and I'm definitely gonna die.
I don't understand why BC like breaks on and off all the time.
It's actually like...
It's so annoying.
It's so fucking annoying when that happens.
I know it's broken cause like Mace always talks.
Oh my god.
You're so healthy.
You're so fucking healthy.
You're so...
Oh, Venom's...
Venom, please.
Okay.
That's fine.
That's fine, he's alive.
You don't need no voice comms.
What the fuck is voice comms for anyway?
Voice comms are for pussies.
If you wanna be a real gamer, you win without talking.
Oh, shit.
I was so close.
I wish I had voice comms to tell them that there was a mantis on me.
There was a cylorg on me.
I'm like, no, I wish I could yell for help.
I'm not even gonna say GG.
We take those though.
We fucking take those.
Oh my god, that's fine.
I'm okay with taking that.
That was... Yay!
Clap for help then.
Guys, I think...
Yeah, I'm happy we...
I'm happy we...
We were able to live for a bit.
We might have 5 deaths, but I blame the lack of voice comms.
I blame voice comms breaking in the end.
Also, I definitely... Guys, I have like a million excuses and I'm ready.
I'm trying to figure out...
Maybe controls... Wait, what did I put for...
I need healing.
Because I know there's no crouch walk, so there's no crouching.
What is it?
What did I put?
Okay, left control.
Alright, left control.
It's like 120.
No, it goes on and off.
Like, I don't... Sometimes it just... It's just like in between rounds that it breaks sometimes.
Like, the game is like almost perfect.
It's actually almost perfect.
It's literally... It just breaks the voice comms.
It's like the worst thing they couldn't... It's just the worst thing ever.
That's really it.
They were so close to perfection.
Yeah.
I don't know.
It's crazy.
Like, nothing... Like, everything else is okay.
I don't understand.
Everything else is like very... It's like...
Well, I won't say very well optimized because the whole, like, you do more damage if you have more frames is a little fucked up.
Like, you know, just a little bit fucked up.
Like, you... It's literally like...
Spec diff, if you guys didn't see about it.
Like, the less FPS you have, the less damage you do.
And then the mouse... The built-in mouse acceleration is pretty fucking crazy.
And the fact that you can't turn it off is a little weird.
It's like...
Who the fuck plays with mouses?
Who the fuck competitively-wise play with mouse acceleration?
And then...
Yeah, the built-in mouse acceleration is pretty...
It's pretty messed up.
And then...
And other than that, everything else is great.
Like...
I feel like they actually ban cheaters every day.
Because I've been getting...
You know, I get like, thank you for reporting!
Thank you for reporting!
And stuff like that.
So they actually actively ban hackers and DDoS'ers and everything.
No, the command for mouse acceleration, they patched it.
So you can't do the config file with turning off mouse accel anymore.
They patched it up in two days.
I don't know why they patched it.
I guess they don't like the fact that you're editing the game files.
Which makes sense, because a lot of devs don't like that.
Like editing the game files itself.
So I'm not that surprised that they edited that out.
Still a little cringe, yeah.
Oh, we don't get them again!
I thought we would get them.
I shine in darkness.
Yeah, but if it's not there now, they might as well let us have the config.
Yeah, but what's the point of patching it if you're gonna bring it back anyway?
You might as well put it... I don't understand though, because they don't want to...
They don't want to have people editing the game files.
But still, if you're gonna bring it, bring it.
Why not bring it back?
Bring it now.
You know I'm the best DPS player in NA, right?
Okay.
Sure.
Um...
Hello?
Are they bad, huh?
Cause like, Mac can play...
Oh yeah, oh man, hello.
I was gonna say, Mac's really good at hello.
Wait, wait, he is playing.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
He's clearly joking, right?
Alright.
I've seen him play DPS in plat.
Oh no, not even plat in silver.
So like...
I don't know.
We'll see today.
We'll see.
Oh yeah, if my mods are alive right now, can you edit in my squad with Mace and Mac?
Yeah, like, that's why I don't use any... I really...
I know there's like a lot of really funny mods for Marble Rivals, but I'm so scared of getting banned for using them.
So like...
Or like get suspended or something.
So, that's why I don't use any...
I don't use any of the mods.
I know there's like... I talked about it yesterday, but I really wanted...
No, two days ago, but I really wanted to... Oh my god, I really...
Oh my god, I'm gonna watch on my chair.
Anyway, um...
Yo, what?
As I was saying, um...
Where was...
I really wanna mod the cart to Thomas the Tank Engine, but I'm scared of getting suspended for it.
We're on their helicopter.
Cool.
I dropped.
I'm sorry.
I like jumped through and dropped instantly.
Put magic on me, please.
I'm sorry.
That was actually a throw.
I like jumped through the portal.
Match is frozen.
That was so unlucky.
Shit, I'm so sad.
I'm so sad.
I can't believe it.
I was like, no, I could've been behind him.
Oh, I'm just gonna die.
I tripped.
I fucking tripped.
Yeah, no, there's some fucking crazy mods out there.
I need to put this on a tank.
Okay, don't worry, tank.
Mace, you don't get this privilege anymore.
You're not tank anymore.
Where's our other tank?
Oh, there he is.
I was like, where did he go?
I hope Mack is okay with not being healing.
Alright.
Of course, the map is changing.
Oh, we need help back here.
God.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, we got hooked.
I don't think my voice chat is working.
Oh, my God, I might have to actually restart my game.
That was so sad.
Oh, my God, that was so sad, guys.
That was so unlucky.
Of course, I get caught.
Oh, my God.
Don't worry, you're all alive.
I'm dancing.
One second left.
I have magic on me.
I have no idea if it's working, but like, I'm still gonna come regardless.
Or they're ignoring me.
It's fine.
I'm used to it.
I'm so used to being ignored.
That's okay.
I hate it when that happens, though.
Oh, my God.
It's so frustrating, because I might actually have to restart.
I might actually have to restart my game, because I thought, sometimes you don't have to, and it just fixes itself.
But sometimes, it's just like, you know, fuck you, I guess.
Like, the game's just like, whatever.
Alright, let's hope our- Oh!
Oh!
Nice!
Alright.
Thank God, I was gonna be a little worried there.
Sometimes, we go a little bit too fast, though, and...
That's fine.
Wait, what?
What do you mean, control lost?
Alright.
That's fine.
We're so healthy.
We were just fucked over, because of the map change, earlier.
That's fine.
Oh, portal behind!
Portal behind!
We're so...
We're so healthy.
Alright!
Oh!
Stop!
Oh, here we go!
I'm fucking dancing!
Oh, they have Strangelord here!
Oh!
And then I fucking fly away, I guess.
Oh.
Oh, there it is!
There it is!
Oh, you're alive!
Oh my God!
No sleeping for you!
Hahaha!
Oh my God!
I mean, you're doing alright.
I'd be better, but it's okay.
Oh, damn!
Mack, you did a great job.
You know, you're a mean person.
You know, that's strange.
Oh, my music is not.
It's not working.
You're bringing the team morale down!
No, no.
You're going crazy.
Oh my God, am I really, bro?
Oh my God.
Yeah, it's definitely not working.
I hate this.
It always happens to me.
Hello?
Is it working now?
Oh my God, he lied.
Alright, we TP.
Yeah, TP, TP, TP.
They don't have TP.
Hello?
He fucking lied.
Hahaha!
There's no apply settings, guys!
There's no apply settings for mics!
He lied.
He fucking lied to me.
I was gonna be so happy.
I was like, oh my God, I can't wait to be able to talk to my teammates.
Woo!
Standing in a line.
Standing in a line so I can...
Oh my God!
Oh!
Oh, that's two kills.
Alright, I'm coming back.
I'm not allowed to yap.
Yapping is bad.
I'm gonna come in with Luna ult.
I'm coming in!
There we go, I made it.
I made it, everybody.
We keep dancing.
We stop dancing.
Oh my God, I'm so scared.
There's so many things going on my screen.
Which one's real?
Oh!
Oh, please.
Oh my God, I'm so scared.
I'm so scared.
All the map is moving!
Like, the map is moving!
Jesus Christ.
Oh my God, I hate this map so much.
Winner one, winner one.
I hate this map.
I actually hate this map.
Oh my God.
That's fine, that's fine.
We're so healthy.
Oh, dinosaur!
Alright.
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
We're still contesting.
We're still alive and very, very healthy.
Alright, except for that guy.
Oh my God.
It's fine.
We're so healthy.
We're still contesting.
No, legitimately, I hate this map.
This map moves way too fucking much.
Like, I don't even know where to position because of this map.
Because it changes all the time.
Oh, Mac, let me give you a word.
You can't hear me, but like, I hope you understand.
I hope you understand.
I hope... Ah!
No!
Not...
Okay.
That's fine.
That's okay.
We're okay.
Alright.
That's fine.
Clap.
You are taking so much damage.
Oh my God.
Nice.
That's huge!
That's so huge!
Please!
Focus tanks!
Nice.
Alright.
That was a really good ult, too.
I straight pathfigured their ult, but it worked!
That's crazy!
Oh, I thought I could get the cheeky freeze.
Oh, that's awkward.
That's actually...
That's really awkward.
How did that happen, guys?
That's so...
I don't know how that happened.
That's definitely very awkward.
The map's changing!
Please!
Please Magneto!
We
did it!
You guys did amazing.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, thank God!
I hate the map change.
This is actually gonna fucking... I'm gonna...
I'm gonna fucking blow up and I have to see this map change for a fifth time.
I'm gonna explode.
Okay.
Oh my God, where is...
Oh my God, he's not even on my friends list.
I can't fucking talk to him.
I can't even...
Okay, I gotta fix... Wait.
I fix... I fix VC.
I restart game and fix VC.
Alright, I'm gonna restart my game.
I gotta restart.
Oh my God.
Alright, let's see if it fixes.
Guys, no, I don't...
Guys, we're just playing.
Each game is a new game, a new life.
Guys, each game is new.
Guys, I don't wanna... I don't wanna go in there super confident and everything.
I don't wanna...
I don't wanna go in there super fucking confident and like, I'll be like, yeah, I'm totally gonna get top 500 everybody.
Yeah, it's totally gonna happen.
Yeah, no, the in-game voice chat keeps breaking for me.
It will work for like...
It's like on and off sometimes.
Also, Adam, thank you for the five gift subs.
Thank you, thank you.
And Rom, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
I really appreciate it.
No, I don't have... There's no mute button.
The Marvel Rivals VC doesn't have a mute button.
So, like, it's mostly... It's literally just...
It just breaks.
It's just...
It's just... It's like that.
How many points?
The cutoff is 120.
But I don't wanna be exactly 120, cause I would just lose it, like, the next day.
Like, I just...
I'll just lose it the next day.
I don't want that.
Alright.
Oh, it should be...
Wait, why is my thing muted?
Wait, it is.
Okay, enable voice chat.
Hello?
Hello, hello?
Okay, I'll just think they're ignoring me.
I...
That's fine.
That's alright.
It's okay.
Hello, hello?
Okay, that's fine.
That's okay.
We don't wanna listen to my voice anyway in-game.
We don't...
Oh,
no.
I give up.
If it all fails, I guess we could go into a Discord VC, I guess.
I guess.
I don't wanna talk with open mic, guys.
Cause then, like, I have to...
Then they'll hear me scream at people.
I don't...
If I go open mic, they're just gonna hear me...
They're just gonna think I'm crazy.
And, like, I don't... Guys, I already have an addiction.
I don't need more problems.
I don't need more problems in my life.
Yeah, but I don't want my teammates to know that.
Like, you guys know that cause this is a safe space.
You guys enabled me to do all this.
But, like, they're just here.
I guess I'll...
I'll change the chat mic thing.
Hello, hello?
Testing?
It's fine.
I just pushed to talk.
Well, I'm not using it on Discord.
I'm using it, like, here.
Like, in game.
It's okay.
What is my push to talk?
Well, I changed my push to talk to numerous other buttons.
I tried, like, one of my letter keys, but it's not working.
And then, I usually use, like, mouse button 5.
Hello?
You can see it go up and down, though.
That's the thing.
Try a little bit.
Okay.
I'll try a little bit of open mic.
No, last time I did open mic and then I did it back.
And then, uh...
Hello?
Can you hear me?
Okay, nothing works.
I guess, fuck me, I guess.
No.
It's okay.
I'm clumsy.
I know my place in the world.
I know my place.
No, I... Why would I get reported because...
Woman.
Why the fuck would I get voice back?
Female talking in my game.
Get reported.
Like, like, female.
Marvel Rivals doesn't want me to get top 500.
No, I can, I can, I can do this.
Is that top 500?
Or, like, if I'm forced to not be able to talk, that's fine.
That's literally how I played.
I literally only started talking in game two days ago because I was desperate.
I was fucking desperate to win at that point.
I was like, if it requires me to communicate with my teammates, I guess I'll do it.
I guess I'll fucking talk.
Everybody's one above all.
Fucking nerds.
You got, that's true, you gotta be top 500 to speak.
I didn't for Overwatch until, like, people started being, people started being weird.
Why Iron Fist?
Is there an Iron Fist player?
I'll do it.
I believe in him.
Hmm.
Oh no.
Fuck.
I spilled a little bit of my drink.
Oops.
Alright.
Oh no, but what if they have a Hulk player?
What if they have a Hulk player?
I'm scared.
I'll talk in game when I'm required to.
For now, if I, if I have a chance to not talk in game, I will not talk in game.
I only speak when I'm, when I want to win.
I do not speak for anything else.
Cause that, cause then it gets a little too personal.
This is a business relationship right now.
Solo heroes.
I believe in us.
Alright.
It's okay.
We might have...
It's alright.
We're in a, we're in a tourney, one above our lobby.
That's alright.
Crazy that in these lobbies, we still...
Oh, there we go.
That's right.
Suck up your fucking ego and heal like the kitten you are.
Alright, there you go.
Toxic, holy fuck.
This is damn, this is why you don't have open mic.
Would be crazy.
Oh, fuck.
They have Hulk.
That fuck.
Who the fuck did that?
Oh my god.
I'll get him.
Like, I don't know what you guys...
Wait, Strange is low.
Nice.
I can't see you, man.
Oh.
There's a...
Strange is low, Strange is low.
Did he just open a portal?
Yeah.
Oh, he opened a portal.
We need a Mantis ult first.
I don't know if it's working, but like, I saw myself pop up on screen.
It's fine.
I wasted the ice, but it's so fine.
We don't need it.
Oh, left side, left side, left side.
Ironman.
Oh my god.
That is...
We're even.
Wait, left side.
Behind me, Syla.
I'm gonna have to ult.
There's a Hulk behind us.
Low, low, low.
Hulk is one.
The only Mantis heals.
Oh my god.
Wait, it's winnable.
Oh, it's winnable, it's winnable.
It's no longer winnable.
It's totally winnable.
Okay, there's a Hulk on me, I'm scared.
Oh shit, there's a giant Hulk.
He's low, he's low.
Hulk is one.
Oh my god.
Alright, yeah, I saw the Hulk run at me and I knew it was over.
I knew, I knew it was so over.
That Syla ult is strange.
Wait, right side, Syla?
I'm killing Ironman.
Oh my god.
Strange, uh, Hulk is one.
Hulk is one.
Oh my god.
We're down like three.
Alright.
Oh.
This is a little scary here.
That's fine, everything is so a-okay.
Oh, that's a good pick, nice pick.
Got you.
We're so healthy, guys.
I'm dancing.
Hulk, Hulk, Hulk.
Oh, guess not.
Oh yeah, this is a good game.
They should have Syla ult, they might Syla ult this.
I don't have a support ult for it.
Oh my god, I'm trying to give you- I'm trying to run out.
Oh my god.
Mantis, you lived for so long.
Boop.
Kill this- No, he killed more than just me.
That was such a great- That was such a good Iron Man ult too.
This is why we banned Bruce Banner.
This is exactly why.
Yeah, we just had nothing.
We literally had no ults for it.
Alright, it's time.
It's time.
Do we have- Do we have an Iron Man player?
We-
Alright, yeah.
We don't need an Iron Man.
That's right.
We don't need one.
We don't need a fucking Hulk crutch.
Only pussies use Bruce Banner and Iron Man.
Because they can't climb like real men.
That's fucking right.
That's what I said.
Oh, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk behind us!
Okay, I might be dead.
Oh my god, he brought the Hulk over and I- Oh my god.
I'm like, yeah.
I just see my- Gets the Hulk in my face and I'm like, yeah.
I'm fucking- It's over for me.
God, you guys are all so- There's someone to the right.
Nice,
nice grab.
Yeah, help his main, help his main.
Okay.
Can you top me off real quick?
Thank you.
Jesus Christ.
Oh!
That's a lot.
Rose Hulk.
Nice.
Alright.
I think season ends when Battle Pass ends.
That's usually how things work.
Get the Nomura?
I'm gonna wear one.
That's usually it.
That's a lot of fucking oats.
They should have Strangel here.
Points moving, points moving, points moving.
Oh!
Goodbye, Magneto.
He almost got crushed.
Rose Hulk, Hulk half, Hulk half.
Hulk low.
I got- Come here, come here.
That's huge.
Strangel, Strangel, Strangel!
I'm trying.
I'm trying!
I'm trying so hard.
I have a Hulk on me though.
Bro, I- We have no supports.
I'm like, what do you want me to do?
I'm just popping!
I'm popping as hard as I can!
All I do is clap!
Hulk on me, Hulk on me.
Hulk is still on me.
Hulk ulted me.
I'm gonna die.
Yeah.
He's still- Bro, what do I do?
I just get clapped!
He just claps harder!
My claps are not strong enough!
It's just, just teeny tiny claps!
Wait, wait!
He stopped me off, he stopped me off.
Thank you.
There's a Hulk next to us, yep.
I can, I can.
Oh my god, I was 96%!
I'm down.
I was 96%.
What do I do?
Yeah, we can TP back.
I think I have well here.
They're looking for me.
TP on high ground, TP on high ground.
What are you, wait, hello?
Oh, oh, oh!
Mac, you have to touch, Mac!
I can ult this if needed to.
I'm ulting it.
That's, that's awkward!
That's, that's...
I'm going to get to her left.
I'm going to die to the Hulk.
Oh my god!
That's so awkward!
That's so weird!
What the fuck happened?
What the fuck happened there?
We just saw him and he just, he just closed it.
I couldn't do anything.
I had like, um, I just had a Hulk on me 24-7.
It was, uh, that was a little awkward.
Yeah, the Hulk was like, straight up just be like, fuck her!
I'm gonna get on her until she fucking uninstalls the game.
Or cry.
And I'm, oh, I'm very close to doing a second thing.
And this is exactly why we ban Hulk, guys.
And I'm fucking doing it right now.
Like, yeah, like, I'm doing that right fucking now.
It's so true.
Ever that shit show?
Fuck Hulk in general.
Jesus Christ.
The fact that the Wolverine brought the Hulk to me and I fucking just died.
I was like, no!
There were two tanks.
There were two fucking tanks.
Why did you bring that other tank over?
You could have brought the second tank.
Oh my god.
What the fuck do I play?
Um...
I guess Loki.
I guess I guess I do Loki.
Oh my god.
That's fine.
Wait, no Mantis?
You're not gonna fucking play Mantis?
What the fuck is wrong with you?
What the fuck is wrong?
Why would you willingly play Cloak and Dagger?
Cloak and Dagger over...
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Yippee.
Three supports is meta, but you need Adam for it.
So we're just...
We're trying.
We'll just...
We'll just make it work.
Usually you have two... whatever fucking support you want, and then Adam.
But now it's just, fuck it, Weeball.
Who willingly plays Rocket?
People who don't have... I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, he's so low too.
Who's on the other side anyway?
Are we on our side or their side?
I can't tell.
I legitimately don't know which side we're on.
I... I don't know.
Oh my god.
Somebody...
Jesus Christ.
I don't... I don't know what's going on.
I hope things are happening.
I hope things are happening right now, because I have no idea what's happening.
Oh, he's coming in.
He's coming in.
Oh my god!
Is he alive?
Please!
Something happened!
Oh my god, he missed.
Fucking nerd.
I... I can't... No!
He didn't miss.
He didn't fucking miss, that's for sure.
Oh my god.
He didn't miss, though.
That was...
That was... Oh my god.
That was a lot of nothing.
That was actually a lot of nothing.
That's crazy.
Nothing happened.
After all that, nothing happened in the end.
That's actually crazy.
How nothing just happened.
All three supports got fucked up.
I don't know what else to say.
One got eaten.
I got pushed by Mag.
It's just...
It's just unfortunate.
Just...
Just an unfortunate team up right there.
Just an unfortunate one.
Yeah, literally that's a rough game.
I can't play.
Our kit is so dog shit.
Hahaha.
He's too busy shit talking to Jeff to fucking listen to the team.
He's too...
He's just like... Our team's like, Hey, maybe you should swap off Rocket.
And he's still shit talking to Jeff.
Like...
You are random.
What?
Shit.
Oh my god, Lucky10, where did you get that ego?
You're on fucking Rocket Raccoon.
The easiest fucking support out there.
Where do you get that ego?
You literally don't have to think.
Hahaha.
Where did that ego fucking come from?
He's not dropping the infinite at all.
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
I can't play.
Holy shit, I can't play.
Bro.
Hahaha.
Sorry.
I'm trying to focus, but I can't.
He turned Rocket, please.
He turned Rocket.
Oh my god.
I'm over here.
How did we live that?
Did I get it off?
I did.
I existed.
Oh my god.
Jesus.
Are you alive?
You are.
How?
Oh my god.
What the fuck is going on?
I don't know.
Legitimately, how does our Rocket have this ego?
Oh my god, are you serious?
Are you serious?
Hahaha.
I thought he knew.
I thought he knew the window was broken.
Who hit me?
Holy shit, what's going on?
Wait.
What's going on?
Oh my god.
I got hit by everything.
What is happening?
What is happening in my game?
Ted, please!
Stop!
Who the fuck is on point?
Oh wait, we actually lost point.
No!
Oh my god, I couldn't reposition myself.
That's fine.
That's so fine.
Oh my god.
I don't know what's going on in this game.
I feel like I'm just...
Ted, stop!
Stop talking!
Who are you even talking to, Ted?
Nobody fucking cares about your opinion!
You're on Rocket Raccoon!
Your life doesn't matter in this game.
You're in game.
Okay.
Why so much hate?
He's like, he's still shit-talking.
Like, nobody's talking to him and he's still shit-talking.
This is why you take out your voice chat, right?
He's just a little guy from... He's been like shit-talking the fucking chat the entire time and like not playing the game.
We were yelling at him to give us infinite and he just doesn't care.
Oh, no.
Just bully me like... Oh, fuck it.
Oh my god.
I don't know!
Where's my team?!
No!
I couldn't see anything!
Everybody was just...
I don't even know what the fuck happened there.
How did we win the point?
Did you kill him?
I don't know.
I got you.
Wait, they're on point, they're on point, they're on point.
Oh wait, nevermind.
Black panther on me?
Oh, I can't see.
I can't see anything.
Oh my god.
That's fine.
I'm alive, I guess.
I can just fight point.
Alright.
I have black panther sleeping on me.
Please!
Everywhere I go!
How do I live?!
Everywhere I go, there's someone there!
I can't live!
There's no safe place!
I'm like, alright, I'll position myself here.
Alright, let me position myself there.
I feel like I get fucked over the most.
All I have is one sleep.
Literally one sleep, that's all I have.
Oh my god.
Here we go.
Alright, here we go!
Here we go!
There's no more to it, right?
No more to have?
Black panther?
Black panther is low.
Careful, Meku.
We can't see you.
Black panther's on you.
Oh my god.
Yeah, they have strange ult.
I don't know what to do.
I feel like I'm just gonna get fucking jumped at again.
They're on point.
I'm trying to be with you, Mek.
Oh, sleeping sleeping strange.
Strange behind us, strange behind us.
Sorry.
Strange is half, strange is half.
Strange is one, strange is one.
I'm on Magneto, Magneto one.
Oh my god, we won that.
How?
How did we win that?
How did we?
Another rocket tummy.
Recruit deserved open wake.
I only have a loving wife and a kid.
Go spend time with the family.
I'm playing it twice that day.
I just need you guys to know the rocket hate, it's not just me.
Rocket raccoon and high elo is universally Okay, it's justified.
Okay, guys.
It's so justified.
Because it's like one of the... it's like, basically, they're like...
It's currently Rocky Raccoon is one of the easiest support characters out there.
You'd think it's Luna, but Luna requires... at least has some aim requirement for like her freeze and everything.
And like, but Rocky Raccoon is just, I climb this, I left click.
And then sometimes I pull the Z out and I hide my E very well.
So, people are mad because like, there's better support combos.
There's better support combos you can play.
Like Luna-Mantis, Luna-Mantis-Adam, Adam-Loki.
Like, just like Mantis-Adam, Mantis-Loki.
Stuff like that, because like, the other team-up support matchups are like, just so much better.
Versus like, Rocky Raccoon.
So, he's just a little guy.
And like, usually Rocky Raccoon players in this ELO, they can't flex to other characters.
Yes, I am a Raccoon apologizer!
That's just Cope.
What about Dagger?
Well, if like Luna is banned, you have to play Dagger.
Unless you, unless your team can like, make sure they don't die.
Because like, if you play Mantis-Adam, it's like really scary.
Because you have to play with super low heals and just hope to god your team doesn't fucking feed.
That's really it.
Oh, this is a GM1 lobby.
Ooh, this is a GM1 lobby.
Ooh, this is a low ELO lobby here.
That's scary.
Whoa, that's scary!
He's just a silly, silly Raccoon.
Just a little Raccoon.
I wanna play Spider-Man!
Oh, we have a fucking, we have a Hulk main.
No, I wish I could just ban your character.
I wish I could just ban your character right now.
If I could, I would.
Ban Spider-Man!
That Doki's standard is high now.
Ever since I, I don't know guys, ever since I got Eternity, I don't really talk to...
Let's see.
Yeah, that's right.
My ego has been inflated.
Now that's an ego.
I gotta, gotta...
Gotta lower myself.
What the fuck is wrong with them?
Spider-Man?
What the fuck is your problem?
But, I'm not a one trick.
That's great to hear.
That's what I like to hear.
So are we actually playing Captain America or...
Hey, he's, he's...
I'm not being pranked right now.
He's seen the Japanese curry videos.
What?
Where are the cameras at?
If I ever face you in rank, I'm gonna play Rocket.
Oh, feel free to.
I'm gonna avoid you.
My game crashed!
No!
Let me in!
I don't wanna lose!
No, my point!
Oh my god, please, please, please!
I haven't lost!
Please, let me in!
Let me in!
Oh my god, let me in!
Yes, but if I don't reconnect in a minute, it casts as a match.
Come on, let me in!
Let me in!
We have to stop them from securing the mission area.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm here, I'm here, I'm sorry!
It crashed because I was shit-talking Rocky Raccoon players.
Oh my god, I'm...
There you go, I'm so sorry.
You're chilling.
Oh my god.
Get off Captain America, bro, please.
I'm back.
Oh, I can't see you, Mac.
I can't see you.
He's chasing you.
We're even right now.
Oh my god.
Oh, we're up one.
Oh, wait, wait, strangers left, strangers left, strangers left, strangers left.
We can match this up first.
We can press Q, guys.
Okay.
They have strangers.
Oh, four seconds, three, two, one.
Oh my god, break the glass so I can go through.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm getting off this fucking character real quick.
I got into that area.
Why do you have strangers left?
He's looking for all...
Oh, and it's me.
Oh my god.
Of course, it's me.
He's fucking lost it, fellas.
It's okay, he's off Captain America.
We will win, we will win.
Oh my god, it's fine.
Finally, at least he's off Captain America, right?
Oh my
god.
We can match this up first.
Okay, um...
I'm a little scared here.
Okay.
Oh, I'm ulting this.
Oh.
Alright.
Oh, I got headshot.
Oh my god.
Maybe I shouldn't have came back.
Oh, I got locked out.
Oh my god.
Guys, I don't...
Guys...
I was even the only one that shit-talked Rocket.
Why did it hit me?
I was even the only one!
I wasn't even the only one that hated Rocket.
I'm going Rocket, good luck, have fun.
Oh my god, no, he mental boomed.
He actually mental boomed after that.
I'm down for a TP.
He fucking, he quit.
I'm down.
Rocket, you shit.
I don't know, they got through in three minutes.
I didn't get through.
This is looking a little dire right now.
And Mesa's...
You know...
You know he's fucking done when he's on Groot.
Oh, he is...
He is not having it now.
He's off Magneto, he's fucking, it's over.
There's a Starlord right behind us.
Hey, everything went okay.
Wow!
We're so locked in!
I'm Groot.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
I'm Groot.
I can't see you, I can't see you, Mac.
Oh wait, not Mac, sorry, it's Tiro.
I'm Groot.
I'm Groot!
I don't know why I thought Mac was the Hawkeye for a second.
I'm Groot.
I'm just so used to seeing him on Hawkeye.
Oh, you're all so dumb.
You're all so...
Hawkeye's low.
Oh.
We're even, we're even right now.
Hawkeye's low.
Oh.
Wait, Starlord's low, Starlord's so low.
I am Groot, I am Groot!
Speak well!
I'm ready to put on a show!
Friends, gather round!
They have Strangel here.
And Starlord will come in.
Yeah, double two, double two together.
I'm just gonna roll here and get Mantis out of the way.
Alright.
I ulted.
They're gonna Starlord ult after this.
Oh.
There we, there it is!
There it is!
I'm so...
I don't feel safe.
I know!
They used both DPS ults, so they don't have anything anymore.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm Groot.
Are you okay, man?
Are you okay, buddy?
Nah, dude, I'm dead as shit.
We're good, we're good, we're good.
I still can't believe I crashed there.
I don't even know, like...
Oh my god.
It just happens?
I don't even know.
It just happens.
That's a huge ult.
Strange half, strange half in there, inside.
Strange close, strange close.
Starlord!
Oh my god.
I can't see you back!
I'm Groot.
He's Groot, he's Groot, he's Groot.
He's Grooting, he's Grooting.
Groot.
He's getting Groot all over them.
Groot, am I?
I'm Groot.
Oh, awesome character.
When does that door open again, man?
I'm gonna freak the fuck out.
Luna one, Luna one in the back.
Hawkeye dead.
We're down one.
Wait, they're low, they're low!
Strange one, strange one!
Starlord one, Starlord one!
I killed Starlord.
Luna on cart.
I'm on my way.
I think I died.
Alright, I'm ulting, ulting on point, ulting on point.
I'm on cart, I'm ulting on cart, I'm ulting on cart.
Ult's gone, ult's gone.
Fuck!
No!
Bro, I think you should just die there and reset.
You're so healthy.
And they have Hawkeye ult, right?
I heard.
Yeah.
We have no bubble.
Oh, Starlord half?
He's gonna do it, he's gonna do it.
Oh my god, no!
Wait, oh goodbye.
Hawkeye low.
I'm gonna pop over, I'm dead.
That's actually huge, what the hell?
I'm dead, I'm alive!
Not yet!
You're alive.
Oh!
I didn't realize.
Oh my god, this is...
This is a little bit messy.
This is...
I don't have anything.
I'm 1%, I got it.
That's alright.
Oh my god!
Hi!
I have a Starlord on me.
Starlord, Starlord, Starlord one!
It's just me and Mantis.
We're coming back, we're coming back.
15 seconds.
Oh!
Guys, this ain't looking too hot.
They have their support ults too.
Oh!
Fat!
Oh, bye guys!
Oh, Magneto's frozen!
Guys, I...
This is not looking so hot.
Wait, Magneto one, Magneto one!
Starlord one, literally 1 HP.
Okay, low, dead.
He's rooting!
I don't know why we're still going.
They have Bucky, they have Bucky.
He ulted!
No!
Oh, no!
Point him, point him, point him, point him!
Oh, we're good, we're good, we're good.
Oh, nice.
You only have Mantis heals over there.
I need to get a cough drop real fast.
Do you want me to start ulting again?
I'm going to wipe with Groot.
Possibly.
Oh, no, no, no.
I'm going to go now.
Alright.
I'm going to...
Alright, I'm back.
They have strong ults.
Strange ult here.
I'm ulting this.
Sion, Sion on me.
Oh, my god!
You fucking got exploded!
I froze him!
Oh, it's too late.
I'm losing it.
I'm going to the bin.
Holy shit, he fucking exploded!
How can I win?
I'm on your right, Sion.
I'm on your right.
Oh, my god.
I'm scared.
There's no one left.
I'm dead.
Oh, Magneto one, Magneto one!
Starlord behind me, Starlord behind me!
I'm getting off point.
I need it so I don't get killed.
I'm scared.
They might have Starlord over here.
I can't see you, Mech.
That's you, that's you!
I'm on Starlord.
Nice.
I killed Hawkeye.
I'm reloading, I'm reloading here.
Magneto one, Magneto one!
I need reload.
I have ult, I have ult, I have ult.
Play on the cart if you need to.
Oh, Starlord, Starlord, Starlord!
I'm dead, Hawkeye.
Wow.
Hey, guys.
I can't wait to defend this for three minutes.
Holy shit, what a comeback.
Let's go, let's win this shit.
Fuck it.
I'm Luna Snow.
Oh, my god.
Guys, I'm so excited.
We do all that, and then we lose.
We are going with low expectation, guys.
I don't want you guys to get sad.
Oh, four minutes, guys.
Oh, my god, okay.
I don't want you guys to get sad.
I feel like, oh, my god, you lost the whole thing.
Oh, my god.
Everything will be okay, guys.
This is Dirky Bear from the future.
Everything will be okay.
We didn't win it, but...
I'm okay.
Surely, four minutes will pass by very quickly, right?
Yeah, it's full push to cry in a minute.
I'll never shit talk another Rocket player again.
Yeah, surely, they'd never suspect a TP.
All right, let's see.
Portal time, portal time.
Surely,
they don't expect a TP, right, guys?
I didn't even wait through the portal.
Oh, my god.
I went through it again.
They're like, nah, we'll be fine.
They won't expect a portal.
You know what?
It's all right, guys.
We did our best.
You know what?
It was great playing with you guys.
Oh, wait, unless...
Okay, I'm coming.
Miz, I believe.
Sometimes the stream just outplays us.
Yeah, sometimes it just happens.
How did that even happen?
So, wait, who all fell for that?
Who died to that, anyway?
Yeah, that shit was crazy.
I died.
So what happened was that he placed the portal and then the Enemy Strange placed the portal right after mid-jump.
My head hurts.
I just got a notification that they're doing maintenance on my internet in six minutes, so...
Good thing this is my last game.
Damn.
That's rough.
Let's draw.
Maybe we can draw, yeah.
You think they'll draw for us?
We can tell them that there's like a hacker in our lobby.
Yeah, just like threaten them.
Be like, draw our DDoS.
Draw our DDoS.
Holy shit.
It was just not meant to be.
Maybe you can do what they did to us, John.
Yeah, they're not even trying.
Damn.
That's rough.
This is like Geo Meester.
I tried to keep you up.
Yeah, we gotta get that 50-50 average for Marvel Rivals.
Some guys just...
Some games are just not meant to be.
That was... wow.
What a game.
I've never seen...
This is literally the first time I've ever seen anybody fall for the fucking portal thing.
I've never seen that before in high elo.
This is literally the first time I've seen this in high elo.
That's fucking crazy.
That's actually crazy.
No, that was one game after Post Rocket.
What do you mean?
It was literally one game after.
Hey, I see a mace.
Alright.
Let's see.
Wait, is he... are they three stacking still?
I can... don't worry.
I'll do something.
I'll do a little trick.
That I know.
No, they have to be, right?
I wonder if they Q-Dodge right after.
Alright, see a mace.
See a mace and buy them back to...
I don't know.
I don't know if it's worth...
I did say like, today's not the day.
We have to go again tomorrow, guys.
How long have I been streaming for?
An hour and 44 minutes?
Oh my god, that's a very short rival stream.
That's a...
That's a very...
A very short rival stream.
Yeah, we'll grind long tomorrow.
We'll do a... I mean...
Yeah, we'll do a longer grind tomorrow.
We can do a longer grind tomorrow.
Yeah, but we're positive.
Yeah, we went positive here.
I mean, we don't talk about this game.
But we won one, two, three games.
And we're up...
We're technically up two games right now.
Technically.
So...
Yeah, I'm able to stop, guys.
But yeah, that was fun.
That was a fun time.
This game was fucking...
This game was weird.
This game was also weird.
This game was weird, but we won.
This game was weird, but like...
We lost.
And like, honestly, we deserve to lose that.
We really...
Even when you're massively losing.
Cause like...
Why should I get tilted?
Like, if I get tilted, I lose more.
So like, it's just GG's go next.
I'm literally playing with a guy who...
Who was rank one.
Like, how would I be sad?
Also, you know why I'm not fucking mad when losing?
Cause I went through hell.
I went through some fucking lost streak hell.
So like, this is nothing to me.
Like, that shit is nothing to me.
Anyway.
Anyway, guys.
Thank you all for coming.
I'm gonna call it for today.
Because I wanna do a longer...
Longer stream tomorrow.
I don't know if Mace is gonna be there tomorrow.
Cause his schedule is all over the fucking place.
But I definitely wanna do a longer stream tomorrow of Marvel Rivals.
So if he...
I don't know what his schedule is like.
But I could try and find others to play with tomorrow too.
Around the same time, like I said, I don't know.
I don't know.
I don't know what the time is.
It's always very random.
But...
Don't camp in my chat.
I feel really bad, guys.
Like, if I say like, tomorrow I'm gonna play Rivals.
And then like, I see all you guys waiting in chat for so long.
And I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Just go in tomorrow thinking I'm not streaming.
Okay?
Just...
If I stream on Twitch, it's a surprise.
I feel so bad seeing you guys just camping out.
Just like, pitching a tent in my chat.
And just be like...
Work first, Doki.
Hey, guys.
Thank you all for coming.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Pause your check.
Get up and move around.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.